[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado al día vamos
a hablar de la ley Marcial decretada por
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin en las
regiones de danés duganza purilla y
gerson en esta última desde el día
miércoles los civiles están siendo
evacuados tras el pedido de Rusia ante
un supuesto ataque ucraniano se avecina
entonces una batalla por la retoma del
control total de gerson pues se lo
preguntamos a Marcos Farías ferreyra las
profesor de estudios rusos y post
soviéticos en la universidad de Lisboa
Gracias Marcos por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de jueves en directo América
de Francia 24 y vemos primero de esta
ley Marcial que ya entró en vigor en
estas cuatro regiones anexionadas
ilegalmente por Rusia y Qué
implicaciones tiene esta ley
Buen día Raúl desde Lisboa esta esta ley
es un poco la demostración de de la
gravedad de la situación militar en la
región de gerson pero también en general
en el sur de
Ucrania en las cuatro regiones
hanneccionadas por por Rusia hace hace
unos unos días la situación militar es
grave para la posición rusa porque desde
finales de agosto las el ejército
ucraniano ha sido capaz de recuperar
bastantes posiciones bastantes bastantes
territorios y se acerca de forma
inminente al centro de la región del
territorio de gerson hay un conjunto de
medidas militares pero también políticas
para preparar ese ese encuentro de
fuerzas que
los dirigentes del
piensan que va a ser bastante difícil
para para mantener la posición rusa
específicamente la decisión de de del
kremlin con esta con esta ley es
poder recortar los derechos civiles
utilizar un conjunto de recursos civiles
con objetivo con fines militares y por
lo tanto que analizar todo todo los
recursos y todas
las posibilidades en esta región de
gerson para hacer frente a la operación
militar ucraniana de hecho ya estamos
viendo algunos algunas operaciones
militares entre entre rusos y ucranianos
y por el momento
las fuerzas ucranianas no están
consiguiendo avanzar demasiado o sea hay
alguna capacidad de la fuerza rusas de
contrarrestar esa última
ese último avance sobre gerson sobre el
centro de la región de vamos a
enfocarnos Precisamente en gerson Marcos
porque digamos la ven los rusos como la
más importante incluso desde el día
miércoles ya se empezaron estas
evacuaciones a los civiles planean
evacuar unos 60.000 civiles que habitan
en esta región de gerson para prepararse
militarmente digamos una respuesta
contundente a lo que llaman un supuesto
ataque de Ucrania los ucranianos
estarían interesados en hacer esta
contraofensiva fuerte realmente como lo
dice el kremlin no O sería más bien ya
que el kremlin las fuerzas rusas quieren
liberar digamos o anexionarse o
controlar completamente esta región de
gerson y por eso están sacando a los
civiles Cuál es la situación real ahí
tácticamente militarmente hablando
en primer lugar esto tiene que ver
también con la aprobación de la ley
Marcial o sea con la ley Marcial es
mucho más fácil obligar a la población
civil a salir de su ciudad a
moverse para otras regiones del Sur del
distrito o incluso hacia Rusia Porque
esa es una posibilidad que después de
pasar el río nieper para el sur de gesón
puedan ser llevados hacia Rusia o sea la
ley Marcial posibilita permite al poder
político y a poder militar tomar
decisiones que no podría tomar en un
tiempo normal en una época normal porque
hay derechos libertades garantías que la
población civil tiene Incluso en Rusia
por otro lado la importancia de gerson
es importante tanto para Ucrania como
para Rusia para Rusia es importante
porque es una una posición defensiva de
crimea o sea es una zona que te permite
consolidar la presencia rusa en crimea y
permite otra cosa permite conseguir los
recursos energéticos hídricos y otros
para para la población de crimea y desde
desde el día 29 de septiembre en con la
firma de Putin en esos decretos famosos
es una zona rusa es territorio ruso como
lo es Moscú o San Petersburgo o sea por
una cuestión de honor y de integridad
territorial del punto de vista ruso es
una zona que tiene que ser defendida
como lo tendrían que ser Moscú o sea
Petersburgo desde el punto de vista de
Ucrania
son es la zona el territorio que permite
una un avance y una contraofensiva más
exitosa porque porque es la el
territorio más lejos del territorio ruso
o sea es más difícil defender jerson que
defender Luján
las líneas logísticas son más largas es
mucho más difícil para Rusia llevar
material militar alimentos hombres o sea
personal militar Así que es una zona
militarmente más vulnerable y por otro
lado es una zona que si hay un avance
ucraniano por estas vulnerabilidad de
rusas Ucrania tiene la posibilidad de
demostrar a sus aliados occidentales de
la otan que puede ganar militarmente la
guerra o sea en este tira y afloja de la
cúpula dirigente de Ucrania con sus
aliados es un instrumento poderosísimo
para demostrar que necesita más armas
que es un Aliado responsable es un
Aliado que consigue sus objetivos y por
lo tanto que esta vía de militar para
derrotar a Rusia es la vía exitosa y la
vía moral